hi this is alex from php academy in this
video we're going to be creating a
simple contact form uh you can see it
here at the moment we've just got two
text fields and a text area uh the idea
here is the user fills out the form
click submit and this is sent through to
an email address with the relevant data
so let's go ahead and give this a go i'm
going to go ahead and type in my name
i'm going to type in a valid email
address now this form field here will be
validated so the user will have to
provide a valid email address
and also a message as well so hello
there just for example
i'm going to go ahead and click on
submit
that's been submitted we've got this
confirmation message thanks for
contacting us an important point here is
that we can't then go ahead and refresh
the page to resend it because uh we're
essentially seeing this sent
variable here
we'll talk about that in a moment though
and we've now received an email from
alex at phpacademy.org which is the
email address that we supplied and we've
also got the message in here now the
good thing about this is we've we've
supplied the email address that's been
provided and we've put this into
the from field so we can basically hit
reply
and this will then send this back to the
email address that the user has provided
so essentially it's just a really really
quick way to get a contact form
submission sent to an email address and
then the ability to go ahead and reply
to that email directly
so that's basically it let's just
quickly take a look at what happens when
we don't enter anything uh which is
here we have a a message here sort of
like an error message that the name
email and message are required
so let's go ahead and fill that in but
just sort of put alex in the email field
for example and then just hello in here
when i click submit we get that's not a
valid email address
so we're validating this field here
now the other good thing about this is
that you'll notice that these form
fields have retained their values we've
refreshed the page
but we haven't actually got rid of these
values which browsers will do by default
so we're keeping these values as well so
we'll be discussing all of these points
and creating a basic contact form so in
the next part we'll be starting to write
the markup and then we'll look at some
php code okay so we're over into our
text editor we've got a basic outline of
an html document here and likewise in
our browser
there is no information here at the
moment we literally just have
a blank page
so what we're going to be doing is we
are going to be creating the form
then we're going to be creating the um
ability to process the data that's been
sent and this will be above the doctype
here
and then we'll output any errors or um
confirmation messages down here
so the first thing to do really is to
create the form so we have a form here
now we're going to have an action and a
method and i'll explain what these do
the action is basically the page that we
are sending this to now we're going to
leave this blank and the reason we're
going to leave this blank is that means
that
all of the data will be submitted back
to the same page so we can display the
errors on the same page just slightly
above the form the method uh describes
how the data is being sent in this case
it's going to be post
we use post data for data that could be
long in length and also that doesn't
want to be uh that we don't want to be
shown within the query string in the url
you might have
if you've ever seen a question mark and
then something and then an ampersand and
then another value
so we're going to be sending it via post
and then accessing it via post in php as
well
so within here we're going to have a
series of paragraphs and these are going
to hold
the fields and their labels so the first
input field
we're going to have an input the
attribute here is type which is going to
be text this is for the name by the way
we have another attribute called name
and in this case it's going to be name
now this is the name that identifies the
field that we're going to pick up in php
we're also going to apply an id to this
because we're going to have a label just
above here
that's going to identify the
label that belongs to which field so
label
for
equals
name we can end that label
and then in here we can just say name
so we're going to have a line break
after that let's go ahead and take a
look at what that's done we've got name
and then a field here perfect that's
what we want
and again this label just identifies the
connection between this field and this
label
okay so the next paragraph down
we're going to go ahead and we'll start
with the label again
and this is going to be the user's email
address or the customer's email address
and that's going to be labeled for email
so now this input type here or this
input field here
has a type of text
the name of this is going to be email
and the id of this is also going to be
email so we can connect these two here
uh the next paragraph down is going to
be the message now this is slightly
different because we're not going to be
using an input type an input we're going
to be using a text area so we're still
going to create our label
just make sure that's ended and the four
here is going to be message we're gonna
give the text area an id of message
um
and we have that message now i've just
forgotten a line break up there so go
ahead and add that in
and we also need a line break there
okay so the text area is slightly
different it's just a an opening tag
and a closing tag
and of course we need a name for this
which is going to be message
and we also need an id as well
which is going to be message well we
don't need an id but since we're using
labels we want to connect them
okay so last but not least is the actual
submit button itself so we're gonna have
an input type
of submit
uh this is just gonna have a value we
don't really need to give this a name so
i'm just gonna say submit
so after all of that let's go ahead and
refresh the page and now we have name
email and message we can go ahead and
click submit which then has forwarded us
back to the same page you didn't really
notice a change if you watch this icon
up here though you'll see it sort of
changes basically reloading the page and
sending that data
so now that we've done the markup we
actually need to go ahead and
um
try and pick out well not try and
actually pick out this data the first
thing we need to do is detect whether
this
form has been submitted so i'm going to
go ahead and create a starting and
ending php tag up here and i'm going to
include an if statement
so if
this is going to be the condition and
anything within these two braces here
are going to be executed
or run
if this condition is true
so i'm going to use empty to check if
dollar underscore post
is empty
oh sorry is not empty because that means
that the form has been submitted
and the post date has been taken um
or re can be read through this page
so if this post
array is not empty
we have submitted a form so i'm just
going to go echo
submitted so we can test this out just
hit the page and click submit and it
says submitted hit the page again
nothing's been submitted but when we
click submit it has been
so
let's just go ahead and briefly look at
this i'm going to go ahead and echo
some pre-tags
pre-formatted tags and within here a
comma separates this i'm going to say
dollar underscore sorry i'm going to say
print
r dot underscore post true now what this
is going to do is it's going to show us
the contents of this post array and it
makes it a lot easier to determine
what data we're actually working with
and it gives us a good insight into what
we need to pick out from this post array
and why more importantly so let's go
ahead and just submit this now you'll
see here we've got an array we've got a
um an element called name an element
called email and an element called
message and they're all blank so how
about we go fill this in uh let's go
ahead and type in alex php academy.org
and hello there
so when i click submit this data is now
placed into each element of this array
so when we want to access this data we
can use this dollar underscore post
array and we can pick out name email or
message or all of them we can loop
through them and all sorts of stuff um
so what we want to do now is obviously
get rid of this
now that we've determined that the
the form has been submitted um we're
going to hold errors somewhere because
we're going to be error checking so i'm
going to go ahead and create a variable
called errors
and this variable is going to be a blank
array or an empty array rather
now what i'm going to do is just define
each of the fields that we need so name
email and message and then apply the
value of these to these corresponding
variable names so name
equals dollar underscore post
now remember we have this array with
name message name email and messaging
here so all we need to do is provide
this basically and that will just take
the value
of name okay and we do this for
uh email
and we also do this for message
uh message not page so uh let's just
pull these across or tab them across
just a little bit neater so now each of
these variables within php corresponds
to the value that the users typed in the
form that's essentially it
now what we want to do is we want to do
a few checks to make sure that they're
empty or if they're empty or if the
email address is valid etc etc etc etc
but first of all let's just go ahead and
echo out each of these values just so we
know that they're being passed through
and we have access to these in php so
what i'm just doing here is i'm creating
oh i'm applying spaces between these uh
echoing out the name a space email space
and message so let's just go ahead and
uh hit f5 and resubmit this data and
you'll see here that we've got alex
space my email address space and the
message so we know that this data is
there we can do what we want with it
check if it's empty manipulate it
whatever we want to do with it so in the
next part of the tutorial we're going to
actually be looking at validating this
and
in fact let's do that now
so we're going to be checking first of
all if these values are empty so we're
going to create an if statement or an if
else statement
and the condition for here is going to
be if the if the name is empty
if the email address is empty or if the
message is empty
we need to
store an error somewhere to output later
so
we're going to use empty
so if empty name is equal to true
or
empty
email
is equal to true
or
empty message
is equal to true now obviously if you
had say another field on here you wanted
to add another field but you didn't want
it to be
required you just simply wouldn't add it
in this if statement and then
this condition would um or this yeah
this condition would be false
so
in this case what we want to do is we
want to add an element to this errors
array so we've created this errors array
up here and errors this will allow us to
just add a new element
and in this case it's going to be
name email and message are
required
so otherwise we want to go through and
validate a few more things so we're
going to be validating stuff like the
email address but let's just take a look
at
how this looks i'm going to go ahead and
print r
on this errors array
so
let's just take a look here when i click
submit you'll see that we now have this
array output like much like we did with
the post array and the first element has
this error message in now if i enter
all the data that's required so these
aren't empty
and i click submit we just get an empty
oops we just get an empty array so
that's great we now know that if the
array if the errors array has stuff in
it it means that we have an error or a
few errors so we can output these
errors
so in the next part we're going to be
doing stuff like validating the email
address and then actually sending the
email if we do have any problems we're
going to come down here and we're going
to output any problems that we have
otherwise we're going to redirect the
user to the sent page and we're also
going to look at the problem of these
form fields which we've basically
already seen
if we enter some data here
and or if we leave our message and we
have have an error these two pieces of
data disappear
uh or the form field data disappears so
we're going to be looking at that
problem as well okay so we have already
built the form and the ability to
retrieve the data that the user
submitted on the form now what we're
going to be doing is further validating
this so we've already validated um the
fact that the three fields that we've
supplied for the user need to be full
they can't be empty
so we use print our errors to check the
errors array that we're appending errors
to we're going to go ahead and get rid
of that and just add another condition
in here
to check the email address whether it's
valid or not
so if the form fields are empty we get
this or any of them are empty we get
this error otherwise we can go through a
list of however many if statements we
like
to perform additional checks so for
example we could check
we might want the name not to contain
any numbers we definitely want the email
address to be valid so let's go ahead
and start with that one
so i'm going to say if
filter var
and this function is just going to
basically
perform a regular expression it's almost
like a regular expression so i'm going
to say email
filter
validate
email now if that's equal to false
then what we're gonna do well what does
this mean first of all it means that the
email address hasn't matched the uh
expression that would be expected for an
email address
so we're gonna yet again append another
email address on so i'm gonna say
remember to escape this character not a
valid
email address and the reason i escape
this character here is i'm using single
quotes here and you'll notice that if i
don't include this it's sort of the
string stops there so we need to escape
this character
um what else can we do well let's just
do something for the sake of it just so
we can get two errors output i'm going
to say if c type
alpha
is equal to false and i'm going to check
the name now what this basically means
is uh
is that uh the name that we supplied or
the name the user supplied must be
um alpha alpha alphabetical it can't
contain numbers
so otherwise we're going to say
name
must
um
only contain
letters not letters letters
okay so
right let's take a look at the um errors
array again and let's try and force some
errors in here quickly
so nothing we've got this name email
message required name i'm going to put a
few ones
or abc1
email i'm going to put in an invalid
email address and just type something in
the message click submit that's not a
valid email address and name must only
contain letters
so now what happens if we just put abc1
but then we type a valid email address
and then a message
we only get name must contain letters
then we
finally say well you know i know what i
can do now so i type all my incorrect
all my correct information and we get no
errors so now we've validated
successfully you can add more validation
depending on what fields you want to add
to this
so now what do we want to do well
uh we want to output the errors properly
at the moment we're not going to give
the user
a result of or a visual representation
of an array we don't want to do that we
want to output down here so we've done
our validation up here now logic up here
now is the time to come just above the
form
and we want to perform an if statement
to check whether this uh errors array is
empty now if it's not empty that means
that there are errors so we need to loop
through these errors and output them
so empty
errors
if this is equal to false then we have
errors so i'm going to echo
the start of an unordered list and down
here echo the end of an unordered list
which is basically a list of bullet
points
by default
then what we're going to do is we're
going to use the for each construct to
loop through each of the elements in
this errors array so errors
as
error so for every error
call it error for every one of the
errors call it error and then echo
a list item
and then between here
output the error
so now what we can do is when we click
submit we get this uh unordered list
let's go ahead and inspect it you can
see you've got an unordered list with
the list item if we go ahead and type in
i don't know abc1 again and then just
alex and then hello
and click submit we've now got two list
items because we've looped through them
errors and output them in each
list item here
perfect so we've output any errors uh if
there are any so what happens if there
aren't any errors well we do all our
processing up here so we need to perform
another check just after our checks to
see if this this errors array is empty
or not
um so we would say here
if
empty
errors
is equal to true so if it is empty and
there's no errors we want to send email
we want to redirect
user so we're not going to do that just
yet we're going to leave that until the
last part but we have a problem here now
if i go ahead and enter my email my name
correctly
i enter my email address correctly but i
forget a message for whatever reason and
i click submit
you get the error message you go oh
right okay i need to you know enter a
message but this and this has now
disappeared which is extremely annoying
so what we need to do is we need to um
create some logic just within these
input
elements to output a value if the
data has already been submitted so
basically what i'm going to do is i'm
going to opens and close php tags within
here
and what we can do is we can sort of
echo out whatever we like so we can say
echo value equals test for example
and what that will do is when we refresh
we get this value of test in there and
that's because we have output value
equals test within here no php just html
output which is really useful
so what we can do is we can create an if
statement here
and this if statement is going to check
if this value is set so we're going to
use is set
and we're going to say dollar underscore
post
name
now if this is equal to true that means
that
um
name has been set i.e
does it exist is it available
um
does yeah basically does it exist
in that case we want to go ahead and
echo
value equals
and then
some data in here
so we'll go ahead and just concatenate
on not concatenate but use
comma separated values for the echo
construct
and we want to echo out dollar
underscore post
name what we want to do though is strip
tags and this is important because what
we can actually do is we have this
problem where uh we can pass through any
any code that we like really in here um
i don't see it being a massive issue
here to echo um strong and then my name
um
yeah so we basically want to strip these
out there's this i mean it's not a
massive issue but we'll go ahead and do
it anyway so strip tags
name
and what this will mean is that when we
enter tags like we just did
and click submit uh they're stripped out
of there so just really sanitizing
generally sanitizing
so with the same with email let's go
ahead and do exactly the same thing in
fact we can just go ahead and copy and
paste this just really to save time more
than anything
and we can just go ahead and change
around these values so this will be now
email and this will be email
now for the text area it's exactly the
same
but this time it doesn't go in a value
it goes within the text area
tags
and that's message
and message
so let's go ahead and just submit
something so i'll go ahead and submit
alex my email address and i won't fill
that in i click submit um these have
these have stayed the same this i
completely forgot that we added value
equals something so we don't need that
at all
as i said it just it's just text that
goes within there
let's go ahead and refresh click
continue and there we go
so now i can type in hello
and that's fine
if i for example enter an incorrect
email address
it tells me but all this data is still
available for me to go and correct
so we've now created it so it's a lot
easier to use and it's it flows a bit
better but now is actually sending email
time now if you are working on a local
server you're going to need to set up
either smtp email or
configure your
installation of apache php to handle
sending email or your installation of
php
and we have a video tutorial on this so
you can go ahead and watch that now
um so we're going to be using the mail
function to send the email
so
what we need to do is we need to provide
four parameters here so i'm just going
to go ahead and create these now
and what we need to send is we need to
send to the email address that we want
this to arrive at so in that case that's
going to be my email address so all
contact form submissions are going to go
to my email address here is going to be
the subject so i'm just going to call
this contact form
and here is going to be the body so in
this case it will literally just be the
message from the user
uh what we're going to have now is um
the headers from so from would be
and then the email address so we want to
concatenate on
email and this will this will show that
it's from this user's email address and
therefore we can directly reply back to
them as we saw in the first part of the
video
okay so what we now want to do is
redirect the user to a page that's going
to allow us to say your message has been
sent not show the contact form
and not allow the user to hit f5
repeatedly to keep contacting us
and in this case it's going to be
exactly the same page we're just going
to pass a get parameter or get variable
along to this page
so we're going to use the header
function and then we're going to exit
afterwards
and in here we need to say location and
then we need to give a location that we
want to redirect to in this case it's
going to be index.php
the query is just going to be sent and
that's it
so
what do we do now well let's go ahead
and just check this works first so alex
type in my email address
type in a message
click submit
okay so it's been we've been sent to
index.php and then a query sent
go over to my inbox and the email
address uh sorry the email has arrived
with a message so it's all working in
that sense
but now we need to actually say to the
user well you know it's been sent
so what do we do well we need to pick up
on the fact that if this has been passed
or not this sent thing here
so what do we do well
down here just above here we want to say
if
something
so if is set
equals true
we're checking for underscore get this
time not underscore post and we want to
check for sent
if uh this is set
i.e
if this is here
we want to go ahead and echo
thanks for contacting us within
paragraph tags
otherwise
we want to do all of this
down to just underneath the for or just
the last part of the form so i'm going
to open php tags and put an ending
bracket there so you can see that my
text editor highlights this start of
this bracket here and end there i'm
going to go ahead and indent all of this
just for readability
so let's run through this the user
submits something we process everything
as we've already discussed if there are
no errors we send the email redirect the
user to sent the page then loads this is
this uh this uh evaluates to false so
none of this runs
but in fact we come down and we say if
is set sent which it should be if we
have no errors it echoes this out
otherwise if the users just landed on
the page this doesn't count so we just
output all of this stuff here so it's
entirely logical if it doesn't make
sense run through it very carefully and
look at the process and it should make
sense so now let's go ahead and just do
this once more time one more time sorry
name
email address and let's just change this
to something like
fred
hello there
and i'll also do a new line
go ahead and click submit
there we go so we've got this sent here
thanks for contacting us we hit f5
nothing happens it can't refresh this
we've got contact form here from fred
phpacademy.org hello there and we have
some new line data
so we have now created a
contact form using php